As an inquisitive and interpretative species,
we are always working to examine, critique,
and improve the world around us.
We want what’s best for the world and we
all like to believe that we know what’s
best for it.
As a result, we constantly judge and critique
the things we encounter in life, including
other people.
This innate competitive self-confidence is
well-intended, but it often results in a pessimistic
judgment of other people.
What we must understand is that there are
two sides to the coin of self-confidence.
On one side, it is good to have a unique perspective
of the world that we believe in and work for.
But on the other side, we must not take it
so far as to let it become negative and limiting.
Progression, revelation, and wonder cultivate
outside of our bubbles of ideology, and if
our self-righteousness is too rigid, we close
our self off from such opportunity.
We must balance both sides and free ourselves
of rigid self-righteousness.
We must remind ourselves that just as valuable
as our views and ideals are to us, so are
other views and ideals to other people.
If we do not want others to discard and belittle
the ways in which we live, we must ensure
that we are not discarding or belittling the
way in which others live.
We must work to develop and improve our sense
of the world through open-mindedness.
We must utilize our unique human capacity
for empathy.
When you focus on empathy, you understand
that just as others are imperfect, so are
you.
When you admit this, you balance judgment
out and neutralize its harmful effects.
You no longer feel as though you are above
anyone, and as a result, no longer feel as
though you are beneath anyone.
In reducing your degree of self-righteousness,
you reduce irrational and unnecessary negativity
in your life.
In its place forms a heightened openness and
opportunity to learn, experience, and connect.
You become open to life, and life becomes
open
to you.